STEPHANIE WONG: So hey, Ed,
now for our Hipster Shop app,
we've got some basic
services set up.
But my site is getting so
popular, I need to do more.
ED HOFMANN: Istio can
help with that too.
There are all kinds of advanced
traffic management features
you can do to
control your content.
STEPHANIE WONG: Great.
So does that mean
that you're going
to show me how it works before
my site becomes too mainstream?
ED HOFMANN: Sure thing.
Let's jump right into it.
[MUSIC PLAYING]
So right away, we're at
Hipster Shop version one.
We can scroll
through the web page.
We can click on products.
And we can figure out if we want
to add them to our cart or not.
But right away, let's
take a step back here.
Let's go back to our main page.
And let's figure out
how we want to do
routing to our front ends.
So first, here,
we'll run a command
to see the different front
ends that we're running.
And you see right
here, we're running
three different versions
of our front end.
So what we'll do now
is we'll take a look
at the virtual services
that are running,
and we'll take a look to
see what the front end
virtual service
is actually doing
and how it's routing
traffic currently.
So when we run
this command, we'll
see here that all
the traffic is being
routed to some subset of our
pods known as version one.
Now what does V1 mean?
So here what we'll do is we'll
take a look at the destination
rules.
And in particular, we'll
take a look at the front end
destination rule to
see what V1 means.
When we take a look
at this, we see
that V1 relates to version
one of our application,
V2 to version two, and
V3 to version three,
a nice, simple way of
keeping all this organized.
So right here, we have a user
that's already on the web page.
So let's take a look
at what we would
do to route this user's traffic
to version two of the web page.
So this user has a
shop session cookie,
so we'll apply that into
our virtual service,
and we'll apply this YAML file.
And we'll go and we'll take
a look at our web page.
We'll reload the page.
And we notice now that this
user is currently being routed
to version two of the web page.
So we'll take this again link.
We'll go into an
incognito window.
And we'll see what
other users are seeing.
And you see right away
that they're being routed
to version one of the web page.
So now that's great
and all, but what
if we want to do some canary
deployments or some 80-20
or traffic splitting between
our different versions?
So the next thing
we'll do is we'll
take a look at a YAML
file, which shows us
what it would look like to
spilt traffic 75% to version one
and 25% to version
three for all users
who are currently
not on the page.
So right here, it's just as
simple as adding a weight
to the YAML file.
So we'll go ahead
and apply this,
and then we'll go back
and check on our web page.
So for the user that
currently has a session ID,
we'll keep refreshing the page.
And if you notice
here, it's still
being routed to version
two of the website.
So now let's open
another incognito window,
and let's see what's
going on for what
all the other users see.
So you see right away that
they're at Hipster Shop version
one.
If we reload the page
a couple of times,
we should see about one
in every four refresh
get routed to version
three of the web page.
Now, this gives you a very
simple way to route traffic
and do some splitting
between your services.
And simple enough, that was
traffic management with Istio.
STEPHANIE WONG: And
it was as easy as that
to do weighted
traffic distribution
to different
versions of our app.
ED HOFMANN: Yeah.
Behind the scenes, Istio is
doing all the routing and work,
making it super
easy for dev ops.
Don't forget to like,
comment, and subscribe
for our next episode on Istio.
STEPHANIE WONG: And if you'd
like to get in contact with us,
click on the link
in the description.
[MUSIC PLAYING]